i saw this photo that you posted you
said
little dude in the back pretending he
didn't eat half my sando
they don't ever ask my kids just walk up
and take my stuff
does that happen all the time to you yes
you know what's so funny i remember
actually before i had kids i have a
cousin
who uh first cousin i'm really close to
her name's lisa and i remember hers
telling me
she's like having kids is the best thing
in the world but it's a totally
different game she's like i mean you
make yourself a whole sandwich and then
they just like take it
and you don't even care you just give
them the sandwich but
i've always remembered that so yeah i
mean they'll they definitely
um i think it's good when kids feel like
that
level of healthy entitlement for a
parent and like what you're supposed to
provide for them you know
yeah well i think a healthy dose of
entitlement not too much
want more fun stuff i thought so check
out these videos floating around my head
this one is really cool i'm just saying
no pressure